at the height of what is an existential
crisis at headingley with yorkshire
county cricket club grappling with its
own racism
they sent in one man to face up to it
as he started he took a deep breath
i fundamentally believe there should be
a period of truth
and reconciliation to get to the bottom
of our culture
and our processes
to learn from our mistakes and
re-establish trust
as a lifelong cricket fan from bradford
he says he understands the game and he
understands racism he's spoken at length
to azim rafiq the former player who was
a victim of racism here and he's now
settled his employment case with the
club
azeem is a whistleblower
and should be praised as such
and it should never
have been put through this
and i'd like to apologize to him
we're sorry for what you and your family
experienced
and the
way in which we've handled this
what happened to you
must never happen again
to anyone can any players who have been
found to have been racist
continue to represent and play for
yorkshire
i think appropriate sanctions
where necessary will have to happen
as imrafeek said in a statement i
brought a legal claim because the club
refused to acknowledge the problem and
create change
for the first time that i can remember i
have hope this might happen
last week the list of sponsors
withdrawing their support grew by the
day they're also now banned from hosting
international cricket until they turn
things round while he clearly gets the
depth of the crisis here at headingley
there is also a conflict because the new
chairman talks about urgent and seismic
change here that has to come from within
while the director of cricket and
long-standing chief executive remain in
their jobs
some of the members of this club are
pushing for an emergency meeting to try
and remove the senior figures who are
still running this club
i think they need to go i think they
would need to go sooner rather than
later but until we have a more inclusive
board yeah representing the communities
that yorkshire wants and needs to serve
i i think we'll just have stalemate
lord patel admits that he is still
working out what needs to happen here he
knows it will be an uncomfortable
process
but is one that has to happen
tom parmenter sky news headingly